[Music]
I assure you brother The Sun will shine
on us again
our resurrection is this time it's just
saying shock my truck hey everybody its
charlie there's a bunch of new low-key
theories floating around for why he's
back during Avengers 4 so I wanted to
explain because no resurrections this
time but he also goes out on the line I
assure you brother the Sun will shine on
us again meaning that things will be ok
so in true fashion he's being very
confusing and we know that he's coming
back during Avengers 4 we've even got a
look at some of the scenes so I'll
explain how he's back in what this all
means and why they sent him out like
this so let's break it down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so keep in mind
that infinity war and Avengers 4 were
written to be a bookend for all these
characters even though we know that some
of them are gonna continue into phase 4
Chris Hemsworth among them Thor will
continue forward in the timeline into
phase 4 and there's always the chance
that actors come back because movies are
set in the past or there's a
hallucination like when they did that
Captain America seen during Thor the
dark world much better Chris Evans
wasn't really in that movie it was Loki
pretending to be him so there are a lot
of different ways for dead characters to
come back so just remember that the Sun
will shine on us again and Loki is one
of the more clever Marvel characters
even though he was sort of wound up by
dr. strange during Thor Ragnarok
technically I do think the Doctor
Strange has much more powerful magic
than Loki but you have to imagine that
Loki's been alive a lot longer so that's
why people are having such a hard time
believing that this is the end of Loki
completely like we know he's coming back
during Avengers 4 we saw this scene
what's going on so the new theory that I
saw is that because he's using his left
hand and Loki is traditionally
right-handed there was something
different going on in this moment
because he probably knew that he
wouldn't be able to kill Thanos
why was he sacrificing himself if he
knew it wouldn't work it feels weird so
what I think the writers wanted to
happen in this moment here is as they
wanted to payoff that moment from the
dark world where he sacrificed himself
but it turned out to be a trick so he
wasn't being that noble remember they
turned it into a big funny scene during
thor ragnarok that was what the play was
all about look at how noble loki is they
built a statue to him he was such a hero
but it was all a great big joke because
he was still alive pretending to be Odin
I was her father
[Music]
[Applause]
infinity war and Avengers 4 are meant to
pay off a lot of these big moments in
the past ten years in a bunch of
different movies so this moment was
meant to be peak hero Loki
so first big things that I think is
going on here is that they're not gonna
roll this back like he says no
resurrections I think that line means
from the writers that this version of
Loki will not come back via resurrection
but he will come back and because they
wanted to feel like a real sacrifice him
being a real hero this is our Loki it's
not somebody else pretending to be Loki
the Russos also confirmed that some of
the deaths during infinity war were
meant to be permanent meaning they
wouldn't get rolled back and that gets
into how people died during the movie
there were two main ways that they did
that one there were all the people that
were snapped in turn to ashes then two
there were the people that were killed
in combat so you have people like vision
where Thanos just rips the mind gem out
of his forehead his body has left their
posts snap you have to assume that
Loki's body was just sort of floating in
the vacuum of space somewhere because if
Thor's body was strong enough to survive
that big blast when Thanos left then
there's probably some of Loki's body
that's floating around there too they
didn't really explain what they did with
that is they're still floating there or
Thor did something with it with the help
of the guardians to give him some sort
of eulogy but it's important that Thor
believed that Loki is dead so I don't
think that this is any kind of trick
Loki probably sacrificed himself knowing
that it wouldn't work to give Thor the
push he needed to eventually defeat
Thanos he had to seek out Stormbreaker
remember how their father's death
brought them together again their
mother's death during Thor the dark
world usually the death of someone close
to him is what pushes Thor to level up
think of it as like a Dragon Ball
situation he has to level up like Goku
but in order for that to happen he has
to lose something very important to him
and in this moment that thing is Loki so
I think all these scenes that we see him
in during Avengers 4 aren't going to
undercut this sacrifice that he made
meaning they're really like two big ways
that Loki can come back because remember
what we learned based on that ant-man in
the wasp post-credits scene so just
careful for spoilers for the end of that
movie if you have not seen it yet
but at the end of a man
wasps they heavily imply that ant-man
will be traveling through time and space
through the use of the quantum realm the
time vortices are Super Mario warp pipes
that can just port you out into the past
or the future we have no idea plus the
idea that the quantum realm exists in
multiple different realities traveling
through the multiverse using quantum
energy so remember multiverse there are
infinite Loki's there's a Loki in the
past that's alive and well so
everybody's been wondering about the
Loki here in what looks like a moment
from the first Avengers film where he
has that muzzle on after they've taken
him because it looks like they travel
into the past but the Russos have said
that it's ba are effing technology from
civil war so this isn't really happening
even though we think that that isn't
totally true there's some sort of
quantum factor in play here which
implies a multiverse but the Russos also
confirmed that they were balancing these
two movies infinity war and Avengers 4
between the many many characters that
they had to handle meaning people that
got really important big scenes during
infinity war weren't gonna be really big
characters during Avengers 4 so I don't
expect to see a whole lot of Loki during
Avengers 4 I think he's around for
scenes like this where they're going
back to visit moments in their early
history where they're trying to get more
clues about fighting Thanos traveling
around the multiverse and time and space
we know there's a scene at the end of
the movie with 60 plus characters from
both these movies in frame together just
like some crazy big scene why would you
do a big crowd shot like that second
backup theory how do you end something
this major in a happy way probably with
the wedding that Tony and pepper were
talking about I've already done videos
about why they were talking about the
wedding and why they're setting that up
for Avengers 4 but based on what the
roosters have said I don't think they
intend to rollback
Loki's sacrifice so when he says the Sun
will shine on us again I think it's more
of a metaphor for Thor creating new
Asgard in Norway and Loki shining down
on him from Valhalla the way that Odin
did during Thor Ragnarok
No
you're stronger
yes we do have to say that Loki is not
an Asgardian he shouldn't be able to
enter Valhalla because he's a frost
giant but I think based on the way the
MCU treats Norse mythology Odin has the
ability to bend those supernatural rules
just remember MCU plays it fast and
loose with those kinds of rules so if he
comes back in movies further ahead in
the timeline think of him as more like
force ghost Yoda
because Odin was able to speak to Thor
from Valhalla meaning that Loki could do
it too let me know in the comments
though when Loki said the Sun will shine
on us again brother I assure you
what do you think that he meant next
week is the official release date for
all these bonus features and deleted
scenes from infinity war so I'll do
videos for that stuff when it posts but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Matthew Barnett
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new Marvel click here for my venom
Comic Con trailer video and click here
for all the other big trailers thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]